much of our attention has been focused
of late on the rise of the imperial
presidency
the president's use of executive orders
discretion
wide discretion
creative interpretation
to advance policies often contrary to
legislative authority
uh to extend that this can remind us if
we have a broader historical view as we
do here at hillsdale
uh of reminds us the prerogative powers
that kings used to use to get around the
rule of law
things like that which launched the
american revolution
that's a grave threat to liberty
but it's also a symptom
of something else and it masks another
problem
which is the complete and utter collapse
of congress as a constitutional
institution
the collapse of the legislative body
itself
and thus its inability
to check the modern executive
that institution's muscles are so
atrophied
to the point where
to exert pressure against the modern
executive they what turn to the courts
sue them
good luck with that
we now have to ask the question
where do we begin to rebuild the
constitutional congress
how do we begin
or whether we can begin
this is still possible to do so one
person who's been thinking about this
and writing about this very well is our
guest today
chris smith
is a distinguished fellow at the hudson
institute here in washington dc
he was president of the american
enterprise institute for public policy
research from 1986 to
he's
2008.
graduate of harvard college in the
university of chicago law school
he was in the richard nixon
administration where he worked on urban
environmental policy
and then in ronald reagan's
administration where he was at the
office of management and budget
and in between he taught at the harvard
uh kennedy school
he writes extensively and very well and
has a wonderful cover story i commend to
your interest
with the weekly standard on this
question and is speaking to us today
about recovering a constitutional
congress chris smith
matt thank you very much
president arn mrs arn
ladies and gentlemen
i know there are many students here this
is hillsdale so ladies and gentlemen
covers all of the students i know
it is mid-september
which is an ideal time to observe
constitution day in washington d.c
the three constitutional branches
legislature executive judiciary
are back from their summer breaks they
are regrouping
and laying plans for a new season of
checks and balances
the scheme of separated powers
was ordained by our powder wigged
founders
228 years ago
and yet here we can see it in real time
and modern dress a living
breathing perspiring organism
and classically american government by
organized rough and tumble
our constitution is often treated as a
reliquary worthy of reverence but no
longer of much practical use
filled with outmoded requirements that
are impediments to sensible
business-like government must be worked
around or politely ignored
yet the constitution reflects in many
deep and subtle ways
the character of the people who
established it and who have lived and
prospered under it for centuries down to
today
this is particularly true of of its
structural features of federalism
and separated powers which embody
americans democratic nature
our distrust of power and our taste for
open competition
the struggle for power and advantage is
a constant of human society
in democracies that struggle is
organized and advertised in political
campaigns and elections
it is equally present within government
but here it is not always observable
in the parliamentary system of europe
parliamentary systems of europe open
competition ends with the election
returns and the formation of a
government
at this point legislative and executive
powers are fused
struggles over policy personal advantage
continue
but are shrouded working themselves out
in private within the ministries and
leadership councils a well-led
government can present a unified
dignified confident face to the public
the press and the opposition in
parliament
that is seldom possible in the american
system
here competition in government is naked
out there exposed for everyone to see
the two political branches possess
separate electoral bases
and are assigned powers which overlap
somewhat that include important
independent elements so they are
co-dependent and must work out their
differences in public
presidents executive officials congress
folk may bring to the fray astute
tactics
compelling rhetoric
but
inevitably in the heat of contention
they are also prone to diatribes bluffs
missteps backtracking humiliations
dignified our process is not
europeans who disdain our cowboy
capitalism may think we have a cowboy
government to match
parliamentary systems have strengths but
open competition is the american way
checks and balances are an important
means
of policing the corruption and abuse
that arise whenever power is monopolized
they are also a means for pursuing two
things that americans care about
especially
limited government and humble leaders
the sheer cumbersomeness of the
constitutional structure usually
requires extended negotiation leading to
a substantial consensus before the
government can act
the spectacle of continuous public
extemporizing
makes it difficult for our leaders to
pretend that they are in command of
events
joseph schumpeter observed that the
democratic leader quote might be likened
to a horseman who is so fully engrossed
in trying to keep in the saddle that he
cannot plan his ride
americans can see that every day
but the whole thing depends on a
reasonable balance of power among the
three constitutional branches and we are
losing that
in recent decades power has shifted
dramatically away from congress
primarily to the executive but also to
the judiciary
part of the shift has come from
presidents executive agencies and courts
seizing congressional prerogatives this
is the part of the story that has been
so much in the news recently
president obama has effectively
rewritten important provisions of the
affordable care act obamacare
immigration other statutes while
circumventing the constitution's
requirements of senate approval for
senior executive appointments
the environmental protection agency has
contorted the clean air act beyond
recognition to regulate carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gases and it has
done so after congress declined after
extended deliberation to embark on such
regulation for the time being
the supreme court has acquiesced in most
of these executive usurpations not all
but most while taking on itself the
authority to decide live political
controversies such as same-sex marriage
it played both rules roles last july
just before leaving town
first the court approved the obama
administration's unilateral extension of
tax credits to persons who purchase
health insurance on the federal
obamacare exchanges then the next day it
ordained same-sex marriage as a
constitutional right
calling a halt to the to the diverse
efforts of state legislatures in
wrestling with the issue
now the court is back
it is suiting up for its new term that
begins october 1st where it will face
many more cases asking it for the
to approve executive legislating or to
legislate on its own account
but the most important part of the story
has a very different plot in fact almost
the obvious
almost the
opposite
and the first of three propositions i
hope that you will take away from this
talk
is that congress itself
despite its complaints about executive
and judicial poaching
has been giving up its constitutional
powers voluntarily
proactively indeed with great alacrity
beginning in the 1970s
congress has delegated broad
law-making authority to a proliferating
array of regulatory agencies beginning
back then with epa
osha nitsa many others
all the way through the obamacare and
dodd-frank statutes in 2010 which
created many more councils bureaus
agencies and gave them highly
discretionary power
under this dispensation
members of congress vote boldly for
clean air
safe products
sound finance
against discrimination against the
handicap
but they leave the real policy decisions
often with economic consequences of
hundreds of billions of dollars hundreds
of millions of dollars per rule to the
executive branch
in recent years congress has even handed
off its constitutional crown jewels its
exclusive powers uh to determine
government taxing spending and borrowing
several agencies now collect and set
taxes or gener generate revenues on
their own in other ways and spend the
money on themselves or grant programs of
their own devising without congressional
involvement
the consequences of congressional self
enfeeblement are vividly on display in
washington as we celebrate constitution
day
congress is now under management of
conservative republican majorities in
both house and senate and it is facing a
left liberal president with a big agenda
one would think that congress would be
busily reclaiming its constitutional
authorities and exercising them to
moderate
not check
doesn't have the power to do that but at
least to balance the president's actions
this is not happening
a harbinger of the current disarray came
right after last fall's elections when
the president lost
his party's majority in the senate when
he announced several revisions to
immigration policies that many
republicans opposed on policy or
constitutional grounds or both
congressional sources promptly announced
that the new congress would forbid those
changes through a rider to its
appropriations for the u s customs and
immigration service
a day or two later came an embarrassed
retraction
staff somewhere on the hill had just
discovered that this agency finances
itself through its own fees and is
completely independent of congressional
appropriations so sorry folks there's
nothing we can do
now
congress actually could do something it
could put the agency back on regular
appropriations but as it has turned out
even that it would not help
it has been unable to pass any
appropriation bills they're supposed to
be 12 of them past covering various sets
of executive agencies and here we are
just two weeks before the 2015 fiscal
year begins on october 1st uh with no uh
appropriations for any of the agencies
congress will be obliged to resort once
again to a continuing resolution a cr
a cr is a blunderblast last minute
statute that simply extends last year's
budget for the entire federal government
with broad percentage adjustments here
and there
the cr is a surrender of congress's
power of the purse
when congress is appropriating
individual agencies it can adjust
program spending and policy elements on
a case-by-case basis when i was working
in the reagan administration
the congress did that to us all the time
it doesn't always get its way
in the face of a possible presidential
veto in my view trying to reset
immigration policy or defund planned
parenthood in this manner would be very
complex and risky but at least congress
is in the game with a multitude of tax
tactics and avenues and potential
compromises in play
in contrast the shut the the threat
under a cr of shutting down the entire
federal government is simply too
disproportionate to any discrete policy
disagreement no matter how fervently
held it would be plausible only in the
case where congressional opinion
amounted to veto-proof majorities in
both
chambers in which case congress wouldn't
be using a cr in the first place even
when congress thinks it has the
president cornered with an unpopular
position
uh such as in the wake of the horrible
planned parenthood uh revelations the
game of cr chicken always comes down to
a national crisis the president is
always the center of attention and
debate and he always has the upper hand
the contrasting circumstances this
constitution day of the president
are complementary evidence of the drift
since his party lost control of the
senate last november the president has
launched a variety of very aggressive
executive initiatives such as imposing
comprehensive uh national regulatory
controls over the internet
i believe he was within his
constitutional rights to do so on the
internet matter but such an enormous
monumental change in national pub
national policy almost certainly going
against majorities in both houses and
certainly and at the relevant committees
would have been simply inconceivable in
the past
and today the remarkable thing about
president obama
is that with 16 months to go
in a two-term highly contentious
presidency he is not a lame duck he is
not close
it's not that he is highly popular his
popularity ratings have been in the 40s
up into the high 40s his disapproval
ratings have usually always been higher
than his approval ratings so this is not
it it is rather that the nature of the
presidency has changed since the term
lame duck
came into
into usage
a political scientist named richard
neustadt wrote a book called
presidential power
in the late eisenhower administration
it argued that the president occupies an
intrinsically weak office
therefore to accomplish his agenda he
must devote himself to continuous
persuasion and popularity seeking
the book became the white house
operating manual for the jfk
administration and every president
afterwards until the present one
what has changed is that the evolution
of executive branch autonomy has made
the president
intrinsically powerful he is capable of
moving policy mountains on his own
and the pre the uh president and his
political aids i believe
are the first to have figured out that
neustadt is obsolete
he works on his political base
he works on fundraising for his party
but he has for years been relatively
indifferent to
the esteem that he has held by the
general public and by congress he has
the wherewithal in downtown washington
right in this building and in buildings
around us to make policy all by his
lonesome which he will do all the way
through the morning of january 20th
2017.
now my title says i'm going to tell you
how we should revive a constitutional
congress and i'm going to tell you that
fairly uh briefly i have a five-part
plan
i've observed that five-part plans are
popular in attention-getting there are
five-part plans for dieting
preparing for a job interview blind
dating and so forth so i thought this
might work for me
the step one is to immediately retrieve
the constitutional borrowing taxing and
spending authorities where congress has
handed these off to the executive branch
should not be done in the midst of
policy contention with the president
all agencies should be put on annual
appropriations
the consumer financial protection bureau
to take one of many examples created by
the dodd-frank act
is
an agency of independent means
it lives on a slice of the profits of
the federal reserve banks
i believe that congress should take that
back make it subject to appropriations
and appropriate for the first year
exactly the slice that it was going to
get so there's no reason presents the
constitutional issue starkly and through
a series of steps like that involving
the borrowing power tax in power to take
back those authorities
second resurrect the spending power we
have a statute goes back a long time you
pass a budget in april and by the end of
the summer you put 12 appropriation
bills on the president's desk
we got off to the republicans got off to
a pretty good start
but have had a lot of problems uh
recently once you have the appropriating
power
the republicans for example could use it
to lay out their own spending priorities
and also
tweak in some cases override what the
executive branch is trying to do
in some cases it could do so
in ways that the president would not
countenance that he would veto
so we would have a drama that might play
into the
2016 elections it would provide a vivid
contrast between the republicans and
democrats but also in just as important
to seek
compromise uh among with congressional
democrats uh sufficiently to be able to
put spending bills on the president's
desk
that would move significantly in
republican directions but that he would
actually sign so we'd actually actually
have some real progress
third
regulate the regulators most of our laws
are now in the code of federal
regulations
not in the united states code of
statutes
in the coming years congress is going to
have to relearn the lost arts of law
making
which involves making compromises and
settling for half loaves
there are a host of areas
where there would be bipartisan support
today
if congress wanted to oust the
regulatory agencies in areas of
financial regulation
the food and drug administration epa
there are many areas of
of compromise
where they could
replace regulations with law today
eventually
we're going to have to rewrite the
dodd-frank act the clean air act the
obamacare statute and many many more
this is going to these statutes involve
vast delegation to actually have
congress making the decisions is going
to require a different kind of a
congress to do these first three things
i've mentioned requires difficult
overarching steps four and five
four is to restore hierarchy in the
congress in the late 1960s early 1970s
congress dismantled its internal
hierarchy its seniority system and its
system of their of strong autocratic
committee chairs the system had been
discredited to a significant decree
because it had been dominated by
dixiecrats who had used it to forestall
civil rights legislation for a long time
they were in decline
but that was a long time ago
since then congress has become
atomized it is not a hierarchy it is a
large congregation of single member
activists
who leave big decisions to the executive
branch and then lobby those decisions on
behalf of local and national
constituencies
the executive branch is naturally
specialized and hierarchical a congress
that can counterbalance it is going to
have to become newly specialized and
hierarchical
itself i think it has to cultivate a
strong internal meritocracy
and
in this conception we would have strong
committee chairman they would not be
unten they would not have uh life tenure
as in the past they would be accountable
but they would have substantial
authority while they reigned
this is not a fantasy
i am a great fan of congressman
paul ryan
and he is my exemplar in this regard uh
2012 uh republican nominee for vice
president he was a natural to join into
the
2016 presidential sweepstakes he said no
i'm going to stick to my legislative
knitting as chairman of the ways and
means committee and chairman of the ways
of means committee is becoming a more
powerful office
once again
fifth
and here
for people who are inside washington uh
and our republicans and conservatives
i'm going to be walking into treacherous
territory cut back
to near abolition the senate filibuster
which effectively requires 60 rather
than 51 votes to pass a bill
and the senate hold which means that
individual members can prevent scheduled
motions from reaching the the floor at
all
these procedures were rare in the past
employing them was onerous and strongly
discouraged today they are frequent and
uh and costless
republicans and conservatives like these
practices and democrats and progressives
oppose them because both sides see them
as slowing the pace of law making and
therefore of government growth
this construct is badly out of date
the great engine of government growth
today is executive lawmaking punctuated
by spasms of legislation such as
dodd-frank and obamacare that propelled
new executive exertions that congress is
then
helpless to moderate
the filibuster and the hold have become
mechanisms of legislative passivity in
the face of executive growth
congressional lawmaking cannot hope to
keep pace with executive lawmaking
unless the senate drops its house of
lords pretensions and becomes a majority
vote legislature
now
um
i said before
that congress has not uh been reviving
its constitutional powers and aside from
the few steps it's taken toward reviving
the appropriations process it's doing
none of the things that i suggest and if
we read the media the media's got an
answer it is partisanship and dissension
within republican ranks
these are unwieldy groups in the house
and senate because of all these feisty
tea party insurgents who will not take
orders
from the old establishment who want to
confront president obama and the d.c
status quo
head on
there's some truth to that but i think
it is highly superficial and the second
thing
proposition i hope that you will take
away from this talk is that the decline
of congress
reflects profound changes in modern
culture and society
we have a system that has a lot of
partisanship
a lot of fractiousness that's always
present but that it is debilitating
to the point of taking congress out of
the congress of balance of power
competition uh reflects these deep
changes
who knows where the representative
legislature came from anyway
uh
it's it's a long story it's a product of
social thought and political uh
competition going back to the greeks and
romans running through the magna carta
in 1512. it culminated in the 17th and
18th centuries with the work of most
importantly montesquiou and locke
madison and other framers it was the
institutional vehicle of republican
aspirations
against the prerogatives of kings and
despots as matthew mentioned at the
beginning
the problem in a world of kings and
despots was to devise a source of
government authority that was secular
peaceable
and generally accepted as legitimate
legitimacy meant not only that citizens
would acquiesce in the government's
power obey its commands but that the
government was to some degree
representative of the citizens
that it embodied
it
furthered it defended the characteristic
values
of the society and its citizens
this was done in some times and places
by
town meetings or by the representatives
being all of the people sometimes
representatives were chosen by lot
sometimes they chose themselves they
were self-selected elites those were the
barons and church officials that forced
the magna carta on king john but in
recent centuries in the in the modern
world it has increasingly been achieved
through democratic choice
elections by citizens voting in
geographic territories local political
jurisdictions
or specific like our senate or specific
districts
that tile the nation created for just
that purpose
the modern age has been
very cruel to this great inheritance
the idea that we should be governed by
elected representatives of diverse local
districts who gather to make law by
hammering out compromises and counting
noses
was conceived and developed at a time
when government was naturally
constrained
by what economists call high transaction
costs when travel and communications
were slow and costly
legislative gatherings were
critical occasions for politicians to
learn of developments in other parts of
the nation to take the measure of
far-flung political leaders friends or
foe
to
forage alliances make compromises far
from the hometown gaze
when political organizing was costly
interest groups were few and far between
established political and civic elites
including the legislature held sway
when surveillance and law enforcement
and program administration were costly
the executive could do only a few things
modern affluence and high technology
have disrupted all of these features
with increasing frequency in the past
century legislators don't need to schlep
to washington to find out what's
happening around the country to form
positions on political questions to plot
and dicker with their peers they can do
all that instantaneously and at much
lower cost through the media the
internet direct communications
well-organized interest groups are able
to monitor reward and sanction the
individual legislature to a degree
inconceivable in the past dramatically
reducing the space for legislative
deliberation and compromises
multiplying pressures for government of
intervention
have overwhelmed congressional
capacities
the disciplines of the committee system
the falling costs of administration have
opened the way to a new system of
government where lawmaking uh avoids uh
the difficulties of legislation and is
handed off to
a hierarchical hierarchical specialized
executive branch that can add new
functions essentially without limit
the
legislature has matt how much time do i
have here
what
a few more minutes
i'm going to uh i'm going to move uh
forward at a very uh at a very rapid
pace i want to mention another aspect of
the problem of the legislature today
is which is modern habits of mind
the modern mind values identity over
locality
rationalism over representation and
decision over deliberation each of our
three constitutional branches has
distinctive principles of operation and
legitimacy
the judiciary's principles are reason
and resolution courts determine the
facts of a dispute resolve it
through deduction and inference from
texts and explain their reasoning in
public the executives are personality
and action
presidents incarnate important features
of the national character they dominate
political attention and debate and they
take personal actions that settle many
matters in a stroke and that redefine
others by changing the facts on the
ground
in the face of action personality
rational decision the legislature's
principles
representation and compromise are
relatively unimpressive representing a
geographic locality is not what it used
to be because of the globalization of
commerce and culture and increased
personal mobility locality is not
without its political importance but
many people today care much more about
representation of their personal values
group identities vocational avocational
interests
legislators have very little capacity as
individuals for decisive action they can
campaign give speeches write letters
question hearing witnesses cast votes
which almost never resolve anything
their primary assignment in our politics
is to negotiate and horse trade with
other representatives of similar
differing and conflicting interests and
values
leading to collective decisions that
nobody is entirely happy with and quite
frequently to no decision at all
should we want to revive
the representative legislature and find
a room for it in modern politics
my third
and final point that i would like to
that i hope you will take away take away
is that
the task of finding a role
for the legislature
warts and all
in that is consistent with modern
political values
is a goal
that
people of conservative and libertarian
persuasion
should particularly be attentive to and
devote themselves to as much as i like
the spirit of the tea partiers
their quest for
promethean drama
to take stands
that parade their conservative
principles
on the television in the evening is
completely missing the big point
drama and crisis play to the executive
if it's a crisis the legislature loses
legislation thrives upon routine slow
make slow
moving
compromise
it is not a dramatic demonstrative
calling but it is an important one
imagine that we had a world where many
more decisions were moved from the
executive to the congress
that would be a world that would
perforce be one that had a smaller
government simply because of the
incorrigible cumbersomeness of
legislative decision making
to say that the purpose of congressional
reform is to restore constitutional
balance as is often said is something of
a slight
its real purpose
is also to restore limited government
not just constitutional government
because congress's inefficient structure
and procedures are themselves vehicles
of limited government
and there is
one more thing to it than that
congress is not just a branch of
government that has to get back in the
checking and balancing game
it is also
a selfie
of the nation as a whole
it not only represents the populace but
it also portrays the populace not with
perfect resolution by any means but well
enough to show each and every one of us
how we look
and where we stand in the throng of
citizens who are our legal and political
equals
a citizenry that permitted this portrait
of its collective self to resume again a
more central role in government would
need to be more liberal in the classical
sense than ours has become
it would need to be more patient with
disagreement including intractable
disagreement
it would need to be more alert to the
improving potential of dialogue itself
even when no decision ensues
it would have to be less insistent on
comprehensive plans and final solutions
and capacious application of state
coercion
to cure every complaint
and it would have to become more attuned
to the relative advantages of imperfect
private markets and voluntary ordering
on this
third of my lab my last uh my third of
my three takeaways i want to leave the
last word uh to uh to jim burnham i
don't know how many people here are
familiar with uh james burnham
he was
uh uh he was one of the
uh most influential lights of the
national review magazine from the
mid-50s uh to the mid late uh 1970s he
wrote some very important books
of political theory such as the
machiavellians defenders of freedom
he wrote
an immensely important book that was a
bestseller at the time
called the managerial revolution in
1941.
it isn't vernon himself is enjoying a
revival and the managerial revolution is
in fact the cover of this week's weekly
standard magazine
he wrote a book in 1959 just as richard
neustadt whom i mentioned was writing
his playbook for the development and
expansion of presidential power
burnham is writing a book called
congress and the american tradition
he has a lot of critical things to say
about congress and who doesn't
in the course of this book and i want to
read
three sentences
from his conclusion and make it mine
to ask whether congress can survive is
in turn equivalent to the question can
constitutional government that is can
liberty survive in the united states
this equation between congress and
liberty may at first seem paradoxical
undoubtedly congress has sometimes acted
in recent as well as in more distant
times in ways that have served to
undermine both law and liberty and it
has done so both in consort with and in
opposition to the other branches of
government
the tie in this century and in this
nation between the survival of congress
and liberty is not abstract and formal
but historical and specific
within the united states today congress
is in existing fact the prime
intermediary political institution
the chief organ of the people as
distinguished from the masses
the one body in which the citizenry can
now appeal for redress not merely from
individual despotic events but from the
large-scale despotic innovations trends
and principles we are beset by
thank you very much
we have time for a few questions uh
before we conclude and i believe there's
some microphones uh coming around the
room
so uh we'll start right here
thank you for speaking uh you mentioned
compromise a lot as your key proponent
to this change
the other side does not compromise
they never compromise
explain to us why compromise is not
capitulation compromise may be
capitulations it's always it's always
something of a capitulation uh
we live in a society where there are a
lot of people that disagree with you and
me so how are we going to get along and
you can say well the other side won't
compromise
i think that the other side
has grasped
the judiciary and the executivist organs
because of much lesser need for
compromise and my program for reviving
congress is to teach people on my side
of the aisle that don't want to
compromise that it is necessary
to maintain social stability which is a
really really high value i believe
but also to teach the other side and i
will tell you that the currently
configured congress
if we did not have
a filibuster rule and did not have a
hold rule in the senate other side be
making lots of compromises
because at this point we can pass
legislation and there are many times
that the legislation would be vetoed but
there will there will be times when we
uh when we publicize issues and move
them up uh to the uh to the white house
in a way that would be excruciatingly
painful uh to the other side i i think
that an appropriations rider
would be a pretty long shot for planned
parenthood but if we did not have
a
filibuster in the senate the house and
senate would pat and we had an
appropriations process they would pass
an appropriations bill for hhs that
defunded planned parenthood the
president does not want that to be in
the center of public attention and the
democrats would start to compromise so
compromise
it moves in both directions it's a
matter of tactics i worked for ronald
reagan
and he was a great compromiser he'd sit
down with tip o'neill and tip o'neill
proposes he said tip you don't
understand i just won 49 states or was
it 47 the first time and it was my
platform was no more business as usual
i'm simply not going to do things that
way
tip would kind of go back the next day
he'd kind of come a little bit further
and um he said tip you know i just love
you to pieces but i really don't think
you were listening to me we're not doing
business as usual in washington anymore
it's got to be this way i really insist
and so tip would go okay how about this
and reagan would say okay
and typically what wait a minute you
just said no more businesses wait wait
wait wait what's going on he was great
at it we have to learn we have to reel
in that art
okay
you criticized
congress for passing somewhat vague
general laws and then handing over to
the executive branch the details to be
filled in later i'm wondering if the
complexity of modern regulation does not
require skills
scientific and otherwise that makes some
of that
inevitable at least to some degree
uh
i i believe that it does
i could not uh
i could not imagine
congress making case-by-case judgments
on the
safety and efficacy of new
pharmaceutical
drugs i think that that's completely
impossible and i think if we had a
national
referendum on whether we wanted the
federal government to control the entry
of new pharmaceutical drugs it passed by
about 80 percent
so right there
i'm all the way to a considerable amount
of
of delegation
but in in the core statutes of
environmental and product safety there
are many many cases where congress could
make the judgments but does not but
simply does not uh does not wish to
because they're controversial and
they're difficult let me um
matt mentioned i worked uh for president
uh
nixon i have you know that i was
actually involved in establishing the
environmental protection agency
and working this was in the early days
and we were conceiving of what the
federal government's role would be in
environmental policy and we thought
there'd be some regulation but we
thought that there would be a good deal
of
public finance of taxation
that a lot of the standards were going
to be set by congress
we got a little bit of what we wanted uh
congress set national tailpipe emissions
standards for automobiles which hasn't
which hasn't been so bad to tell you the
truth it's been pretty good
but in general
they were not interested
president nixon proposed a national tax
on sulfur dioxide emissions he could not
find a single member of the house of
either party who would sponsor that what
they wanted to do was cast a vote for
clean air
and leave all of the contentious
decisions to the executive branch it was
very short-sighted because you make a
contentious decision contentious means
there are some people that really favor
it and so it can be used to
accumulate power i think that in
finance
especially
i think that the
i think that the whole apparatus of
financial regulation could be radically
simplified and boiled down to a couple
of decisions for example
i'm i'm in favor of very high capital
standards for banks i want them to have
a lot of equity behind their decisions
and once there is then we don't have to
worry about a bailout if if they found
her if they make big mistakes their
shareholders pay for them congress could
make that decision and all of this inane
uh
detailed supervision uh with the minutia
of the internal operations of uh
of banks which of course congress could
never do would be rendered completely
would be would be rendered superfluous
oh here comes a really here comes a
really tough one
hello kid
this is this is the reverend
so you and i are old men now chris and
back a long time ago i helped to edit a
book called the imperial congress
and we missed something there at least
maybe we didn't back then but
congress you made a case today first of
all it was a brilliant talk thank you
for it um
congress gets something for all of this
right they get security they get to
avoid hard decisions they get to be um
for their
constituents with the bureaucracy they
get permanence in office
so what motive in them
is going to move them to take up these
reforms you're proposing
that is that is the biggest and toughest
question
congress did not do these things by
mistake did it by by calculation and it
has created a world where
uh the incumbency advantage is very
great because they do a lot of grant
getting
you read these big statutes and
they actually control a lot that's going
on in the executive range but they don't
control policy they control personnel if
you read the dodd-frank act you know the
first thing is there will be a women's
financial empowerment office in every
financial regulatory agency downtown and
it will be headed by somebody at gs
level here and they'll be these branches
and people report to each other
they do a lot of
executive type work and
and it works for the congress and the
great
challenge is
uh as the federalists put it to connect
the interests of the man to the
constitutional duties of the place
that's a rough uh paraphrase
and this was recognized uh from the
beginning and it's become a bigger
problem uh and what what the reason i
think that this has become
such an exigent problem is that i
thought that a conservative congress
facing a uh very liberal president would
be a time when people would actually
make some of the sacrifices members are
going to have to give up some personal
prerogatives
in exchange for some pretty difficult
business of engaging in collective
choice uh with a lot of people that you
agree with a little bit a lot of people
you disagree with
a lot
and it is very difficult i do not think
i do not think that it is impossible
even in the context of modern affluence
and politics and
media dominated uh partisanship
i think the beginning is
the erection of a
hierarchy that will sustain itself over
time
so that when new members come in
they actually have to spend a little
time
earning their earning their spurs
and i think we have to be alert to
opportunities
we're in a very risky situation the
extent of concentration of power
in this country has become enormous and
we've seen little peaks of it the
veterans administration scandals uh the
incredible high-handedness of the
internal revenue service in the face of
the revolution revelations of their
targeting conservative groups
there used to be something called
contempt of congress where you could go
to jail today it's just contempt of
congress it's just usual practice here
in washington and i can imagine a
i can imagine a scandal or a crisis of
some sort
which actually
within the executive branch that
provides an opportunity for some uh
legislative uh uh uh uh a legislative
resurgence and that people adapt to it
cultural norms political norms
they often can change quickly
they often adapt to circumstances
changing on high
very rapidly we've seen that in the 20th
century not always for good
but i think that if a
a determined majority wanted to get hold
of the legislative process i
i could imagine a sequence of events
where that would begin and people would
come to appreciate some of the advantage
of the legislature but i think but i i
it is a it is a heavy lift and the fact
that congress has
essentially selected
for people that are used to running
their own careers and using this as a
base of operations as opposed to being
part of a
collectivity
presents us with a very big challenge
and
what i wanted to say in this
group i don't want to presume on the
political views of an audience or so
forth but it's our challenge